hey 42 here in 2011 the United Nations
declared that access to the Internet is
a basic human right welcome to RIF by
the time a glass of champagne goes flat
2 million bubbles will have popped the
Heil Hitler salute is legal in
Switzerland as long as it's an
expression of personal opinion an
experiment showed that 6% of drivers
will deliberately swerve to kill animals
humans speak more languages than there
are species of mammals plants can suffer
from sexually transmitted diseases
statistically the more rivers an area
has the more languages that will evolve
there if you put a can of Diet Coke in
water it floats regular Coca Cola sinks
because regular coke contains sugar
which is denser than the sweetness found
in diet coke for the last 5 years China
has built a new skyscraper every five
days the sign for the female sex
represents the hand mirror of the Roman
goddess Venus more wine is drunk per
head in Vatican City than any other
country on earth the inventor of
rollerskates first demonstrated them by
hurtling into a party whilst playing the
violin and crashing into a huge mirror
whale milk has the consistency of
toothpaste snake-charming is illegal in
India one in ten Americans think that
hTML is a sexually transmitted disease
there is enough concrete in the Hoover
Dam
to build a road across the u.s. from
coast to coast thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42